houston's police chief says harvey
destroyed or damaged the homes of nearly
400 of his officers still they stayed on
duty during the storm one officer bert
ramon helped save more than 1 thousand
people even though he was fighting stage
4 colon cancer he finished another round
of chemotherapy yesterday at a cancer
treatment center in tulsa oklahoma
that's where david begno caught up with
him david good morning
dana good morning we knew that if we
wanted an interview we'd have to come
here to the cancer treatment centers of
america because he's been undergoing
chemotherapy treatment every two weeks
for the last year and a half he'll tell
you that his life
literally depends on it but but his wife
told us yesterday that when the flood
water started to rise he sidelined
everything about his own safety so that
houston could depend on him
i feel great feel good i feel strong
when houston police officer bert ramon
posed for this picture he was sending a
signal to his wife cindy that's me
giving thumbs up that i'm okay
you know don't let everybody worry about
me the 24 year police veteran became one
of the heroes of hurricane harvey
helping to rescue nearly 1500 people
many were children all were desperate
this is when we unloaded all the
senior citizens from the assisted living
center there in kingwood
for four days it was treacherous one
police boat capsized sergeant steve
perez drowned in his patrol car you've
worked hurricanes allison rita you
helped with evacuees during hurricane
katrina right that came to houston yes
what was this one like
this is like apocalypse it's just unreal
and it was dangerous especially for him
ramon has stage four cancer it has
spread from his colon to his liver and
lungs he does know his platelet counts
are low right
so he can bump bruise bleed
easily she says i know but it's what he
wants to do his case manager diana reid
heard that from his wife cindy there's
no way i could tell him stay home you
can't go he's looking like are you crazy
i'm going
i'm going in
truly are a hero that's what we do
hi bert hey how's it going he had just
finished his latest round of
chemotherapy when we met him sunday he
talked to us about faith and finding a
purpose and god's answered my prayer i
mean it came out of this flood i hope i
can inspire other cancer patients that
you know don't let this hold you back
you know if you feel strong don't don't
let it take over your life at all before
the storm and for his own health he had
been stuck on desk duty but when houston
started to flood he couldn't get to his
police station so he went to the next
closest one the lake patrol division his
colleagues were worried about him i said
hey i'm fine i said
you know don't hold me back i'll go
wherever i need to be was there ever a
moment where you thought
i don't know if this is smart no it's
never crossed my mind at all never he
put his health concerns on hold for the
city he swore to serve as long as i feel
good i feel healthy i'm gonna go out
there and work you know it hasn't slowed
me down yet
thank god
as soon as our interview ended officer
ramon and his wife got in their vehicle
to begin the nine-hour drive home to
houston and we asked him does he plan to
go back to work and the text message we
got back said i've already text my
sergeant and asked him if i could come
in monday morning to which his wife
followed up with a text message and she
said i wouldn't be surprised if he's
back there first thing monday morning
jeff
david thank you very much what else can
you say you need more officer ramones
that's what you can say absolutely
wonderful man